that's gonna be tense
you'll hear the china clanking ted you
wanna be able to look back and i'll just
rub harder and harder on his shoulders
you're done out here
looking back like this yeah [ __ ] oh yeah
you feel that yeah that's a real man
here's a real man
[Music]
what's good my g's
another fun day monday another fun day
monday man happy new year [ __ ]
happy new year
jesus i forgot about that happy new year
2022.
we're going to keep on going as we did
in 21 every monday every thursday you
know the vibes
you know how we do
hope you guys had a great new year hope
you guys have or are still
um what's the word i'm looking for
doing up your
new year's resolutions
yeah man let's stick to them let's stick
to them let's let's break the mold let's
let the smg group be there be the kind
of people that actually stick to new
year's resolutions exactly exactly
um and obviously
the biggest resolution that you should
be following is jumping on that patreon
you know the vibes running over to
patreon and jumping straight in straight
over there um easily done what you want
to do is pause this video right now head
on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs you're
going to get an episode every thursday
you're going to get some discount on
some merch you're going to have some fun
with us in some zoom calls you're gonna
get a
um
flip in
uh
shout out on the episode which i haven't
done
in [ __ ] knows how long and today i'm
gonna do it okay i'm gonna do our
patreon shout outs right now before i
forget for the 19 000th time new year
new us new year new us right where are
my patrons at let me get them up
[ __ ] you know
so yeah guys i i owe you an apology
uh i want to give a personal shout out
to um
was it mikaela that reminded me to do it
yeah from the last zoo yeah yeah it was
mikaela that reminded me to do it and
i've been forgetting to do it all this
time and i will not forget again so here
we go let me get my [ __ ]
right
so
patron shout outs
i want to give ace oh there's there's
there's a few more
there's a few more since the last time
we did this okay right
i'm gonna run through it hot and fast
but don't think i'm skimping over you we
love you and if i get your name wrong
it's not my fault bro it's society's
fault it's the western world's fault it
means i'm not cultured enough and that's
also not my fault right so first things
first massive shout out and a thank you
to
thank you
sarah thank you
sasha
thank you
robin
thank you renardi thank you olivia
thank you nicholas my guy thank you
morgan thank you
um morgan's got a hot picture i'm pretty
sure she's just wearing a shirt and
nothing else from what i can see here
thank you for that
are you ain't gonna see it for your eyes
fam
yeah yeah
um
miriam
thank you matthew thank you matthew
again
thank you bro i'll call you matthew c
and matthew v thank you guys mark my guy
thank you
mariana
markana
that's how you say it
mariana
to be fair to be fair mario mariano with
a janna with a j
lizette
thank you
lina thank you leanne thank you crystal
thank you kia thank you kate thank you
cameron thank you jay thank you jacob
thank you holly thank you ewan thank you
de niro thank you cynthia thank you
clark claire cameron and becky thank you
alexis makida especially thank you casey
thank you and last but not least ethan
my guy thank you ethan from down under
ethan from down under guys thank you so
much we appreciate you always um next
zoom is just round the corner um
and guys yeah you've made everything
possible for us and more
we appreciate it to the cows come home
and if you want to be on that list next
time guys
hop on over to patreon.com
sign up today and we'll get busy with it
um
and yeah i think that's all i have to
say that's what i have to say for today
um today's fun fact um in 2015
the scene from this scene sorry from
wolf of wall street featuring leonardo
dicaprio margaret robbie was the most
paused scene on netflix
let me guess what it was
is it
margot robbie and leo yeah
is the one where she puts her foot on
his [ __ ] face
[ __ ] knew it
he was that kitty cat
he was literally dying look at him
he can't breathe he can't she needs the
pump she's spoken about this more than
once on here
and
her sexual aura in that movie i don't
know how she does it it's unbearable i
don't know how they didn't bang offset
oh same i don't know how they didn't
bang offset like you said before margot
robbie was the yet that was pissing on
me in the show
sam i said i'll pull her to my lips to
my lips brother
i pulled those cheeks straight to my
lips bro
yeah they must have been sexual tension
sexual tension but then again leo
doesn't do anything over 25 does he
he doesn't but i would i'm sure he would
make an exception in that regard for
young margot i'm sure he would make an
exception in that regard yeah i'm not so
i knew it'd be that scene because that's
a scene she looks sensational in that oh
[ __ ] hell
[ __ ] hell that's what she says she's
just giving up wearing underwear around
the yard
nah
nah
what do you mean fam oh just that
constant aura yeah
that fragrance
yeah man oh yeah she's a banging spice
she's a banger yeah i wouldn't be a i
wouldn't be able to handle that i
couldn't handle such a thing i wouldn't
be able to handle that
but anyway i've got a um
i've got a scenario for you all right
okay um this was actually i found this
on twitter a time ago i think i found it
early last year i just never spoke about
it
so
title is is the stepfather wronging this
let's talk about it scenario it's a long
one by the way so just bear with okay my
name is stan i'm a 54 year old man my
wife renee and i have been married for
22 years
she had two beautiful daughters from her
previous marriage the girls were five
and seven when we met
their father who was a doctor abandoned
them after he and renee divorced he
remarried and took care of his new
family
meanwhile i've always taken care of
these girls as if they're my own
renee has been a renee has been a
stay-at-home wife majority of her
marriage i'm a blue collar worker
i once asked her about seeing the doc
for child support
her reply was we don't need him we have
you
i asked him i knew you were gonna react
i knew you were gonna react hold on
i knew you were gonna react
her reply was we don't need him we have
you i asked to adopt the girls but renee
insisted the doc wouldn't agree to it
regardless i continued to take over my
family i put both girls through college
brought bought both a car and was
present at all their school events i'm
currently footing the bill for the
eldest daughter's wedding and helping
the youngest and helping the youngest
take care of a five-year-old taker of
her five-year-old sorry i'm the only
papa the baby knows
like papa in quotation marks
um
i once asked her to help i once asked
her about seeking the doc for child
support her reply oh wait hold on
next slide
put the same paragraph twice okay fam i
was thinking you put the same paragraph
are you having a stroke
midlife crisis bro so right the doc the
doc recently divorced his wife and has
been trying to repair the relationship
with his daughters
my daughter told me she wanted her
biological dads
to give her away at the father-daughter
dance i was devastated
can you imagine i just imagine i
suggested we both walk down her we both
walk her down the aisle renee interfered
and told me i'm just a stepdad and not
to mess up her special day i feel so
broken
i have decided that i will not attend
the wedding nor will i pay the 10k
balance after i've already paid 12k on
the wedding my wife has called me petty
and threatened to divorce me if i mess
up the wedding however i'm standing firm
on my decision is he wrong
all right let me unpack this again
family's gonna say there's a lot of
information let me unpack this again
scenario his name is stan um he's 54
years old he's got a misses um
they've been together for 22 years she's
got two daughters from a previous
marriage from a doctor he's been in
their lives since they were five and
seven so it's been a long last time yeah
yeah the other donny doctor remarried
um and she's a blue he's a blue collar
guy and she's a stay-at-home worker stay
at home working mom
um the doc is now asked well he's now
asked the doctor for um more child
support she said nah we got you you
could take care of us blah blah blah
he's bought the car he's fun there
through school he's been to all the
events he's done everything and he's
putting the bill for the wedding as well
and he obviously he's taking care of the
granddaughter as well yeah you know
the doc now has divorced his current all
his new misses he's trying to reconcile
with the relationship with his actual
his other daughters in a previous
relationship with renee
um she wants the daughter now wants her
biological father to walk down the aisle
as opposed to the stepfather even though
his stepfather's been in life longer
than the biological father yeah
renee told her don't interfere you're
just a stepdad
and he's threatening to not pay the 10k
balance renee said that or the daughter
said that because renee's his wife
renee's the yeah renee's the wife she
said you're just no the daughter said
you're just a stepdad no
his wife said you just said that don't
interfere yeah
carry on
so he's then decided to not pay the
balance of the wedding and the wife is
threatened to divorce him for messing up
the weapon for messing up the wedding
however he's firm on his decision is he
wrong slash what should he do
um
right in my opinion
he's wrong and he's right hit me
so
um oh
actually
i don't know because this whole time i
thought the daughter was the one that
was like you're just my stepdad
so when i thought it was her
saying you're just my stepdad then i
would have been like yeah if he wants to
turn around after that
and say
um
well i'm not paying if i'm just i'm not
paying you a [ __ ] bill then
then
i i would say yeah dude do your thing
but now if it's his wife saying that
like you'll just say step down don't
[ __ ] up the wedding and if he's now
telling if he's now punishing the
daughter for what the wife is saying
then that's a bit iffy granted he can do
what he wants at the end of the day but
yes
i do feel like so here's how i say it
right
i'll go through the whole thing yeah so
he approached his wife renee and said i
want you to get in contact with your ex
about getting some child support i'm a
blue collar worker i'm not making all
that kind of money
he makes p
it's his legal responsibility to pay for
these kids and she said now we don't
need them we've got you you can pay
you got me [ __ ] up for starters renee
you got me [ __ ] up
get on the phone
get on the phone call who you need to
call because you got me [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah rags
rags point one rags
um
i would have divorced it from then i
said you've got your [ __ ] all twisted
babes
but anyway um
then yeah
i'm not a big fan i don't know i feel
like weddings are such a weird
convoluted concept
in that like people people forget
themselves sometimes when they get
married especially the bride okay they
forget themselves in terms of like
her saying i want my biological dad to
walk me down the eyes of
they they lose their sense of what's
realistic and what's responsible and
what actually matters
all they give a [ __ ] about is how they
look on the day she's probably i don't
want to make assumptions because i hate
when you do this but
she may be thinking
how it looks more than what she actually
cares about how it looks with her real
dad walking her down that aisle she
might care more about how that actually
looks aesthetically and how people will
view her that way react to it and react
to it rather than her stepdad walking
her down the aisle
so sometimes for me brides you need to
let brides do what they want what the
[ __ ] they want to do i hate brides
and i think the whole thing is dumb
sometimes but at the end of the day you
have to firm the air and be like you
know what it's your [ __ ] day we'll do
what you want so
i wasn't a massive fan of the fact that
he was that she said oh i want
daddy doctor to walk me down the aisle
and then he was like why don't we both
what you done now
for me i was a bit like why don't you
mind your business
how about you don't make records
maybe don't make recommendations of who
walks me down the aisle
we're gonna
feel who you want to feel in your
bedroom in it
don't come to me about business
literally
yeah as soon as you said about the oh
maybe we'll both walk you down now i was
thinking
it's not your day big man let her do
what the [ __ ] she wants however you feel
about it you can
discuss that after
but yeah like let her do what she wants
that's why when when when i thought it
was her that said you're just my stepdad
then i was thinking oh pull the block
easily pull the plug yeah i'm not paying
for nothing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's how you want to be yeah i'll be
there yeah but i'm not paying for
nothing if you want homeboy to walk you
down that aisle then homeboy can pay for
it like
i'm not even being bitter that's just
basics maths yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
just basic maths yeah
um father of the buyer pays for this
[ __ ] i'm not the father for the bride
yeah he can pay for it i do feel i
understand he's hurt and stuff like that
but
now and now that i've understood more
that it was actually his wife that was
saying you're just a step dad i'm gonna
divorce you if you start [ __ ] up this
wedding
um
[Music]
and now she's even more vexed that he's
decided i'm not paying this 10 grand
that you're asking me to pay like
if i love the door i'm still going to
the wedding
i'm still going to pay the 10 grand if i
can afford to pay it which i obviously
can because i was going to pay i'm going
to pay if she's not the one that's told
me you're just my stepdad and she still
loves and respects me regardless if she
wants me to walk down the aisle or not
i'm still gonna pay that 10 grand i'm
not gonna punish her because my wife's a
[ __ ]
basically that's what i'm trying to say
um so yeah i do think he's a bit wrong
the fact that he's decided you know what
i'm not even going to the wedding like
if you've been raising us since she was
seven years old
and now all of a sudden because your
wife's a prick you're you're basically
being like nah [ __ ] [ __ ] you
like he feels
um
like he doesn't feel validated and he
probably feels like yeah literally like
a step in dad uh and he's probably hurt
by it but i think he needs to get
out of his own feelings
and be like what's more important the
fact that she has a wedding that she can
remember or she's 10 grand in the hole
and she's trying to reconcile a
relationship with her biological father
by inviting him to walk her down the
aisle like
get yourself out of the picture for a
minute and then you can pick all this
[ __ ] up afterwards
um so yeah if it was me
i would still go to the wedding i would
still pay for for the thing i'm going to
pay for i want her to have a good day a
good day as her dad stepdad whatever you
want to call me my wife's done
my i'm done with her okay million
percent okay you can never speak to me
like that i've been raising your two
[ __ ] news yeah on my pocket you won't
even ask for help for next man and now
you want to chat to me like that
it's done for you it's a wrap for you
after that wedding
pack your bags big man
as soon as that wedding's done pack your
bags fair enough how do you see it um
originally because i've read that before
but i haven't read it in a long time
apart from today
and my initial reaction i was vex
because
i just saw it from his point of view you
know as you're reading it you you
automatically choose a side you have to
be doing something you know and when i
read i was thinking [ __ ] that must suck
yeah man saying
man's threatening to get the vote um to
divorce him
man saying oh you're not my real dad man
said i want my real dad to walk me down
i was thinking family's getting blown
off the blower he's getting kidney shots
i'm like he's been there for you you
know he's been there for you but
actually
reading it again out loud and actually
hearing your answer it does make sense
you have to
as a human being you have to remove
yourself from that situation because
that situation doesn't even involve you
in that aspect obviously so if you
remove yourself from that situation and
focus on the actual daughter or your
daughter in or whatever you want to call
it she's um
it's her day it's her priority so you
need to make sure she's happy
and then deal with the mother or the
wife situation another day or another
time yeah that's the thing is just like
i feel like if
women for example they cherish weddings
so much they have one day
in their head anyway
from their perspective they have one day
to make everything as perfect as they
can make it
and if she makes a mistake of inviting
this stranger down the aisle then that's
a business it's her choice but
for you to punish her for that
i don't think it's fair he because
the way it reads is like he only cares
about how this situation affects him
he only cares about how he feels
about what's happening or how betrayed
he feels and stuff like that like he
only cares about
he's willing to take actions based on
how he feels emotionally by it and it's
like when you talk about someone's
wedding
yeah if especially if you're a big you
play a big financial role in this
wedding and all of a sudden you're like
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off and just
because she doesn't want to walk you
down the aisle doesn't mean she doesn't
want you there yeah i'm sure he would
have still been on the head table and
all this [ __ ]
yeah well i would have been like even if
you have to just be vexed the whole day
suck it up for this one day afterwards
you can cancel the whole family
if you want to yeah but for that one day
be a man and be like
this [ __ ] sucks but you know what i'm
gonna hold my tongue until after this
wedding because i'm not trying to ruin
this woman's life because that's all
they care about since they were little
girls that's all i give a [ __ ] about
so for that one day just be a man and be
like
i'll see you i see you i see you'll see
you but yeah as soon as soon as this
wedding's over yeah renee is getting
punched in the forehead
and docky can pick up the [ __ ] pieces
i already know doc's gonna be in my ear
like you [ __ ] i already know it i
already know it if i was a step dad in
that situation yeah we're all at the
head table obviously she's he's walked
her down the house so i'm assuming he's
at the head table as well probably
somewhere yeah somewhere you know and he
walks past behind me like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] he can never
tell you because because you said it
just came to my mind because you said
just hold your tongue bite your tongue i
know there's something that he would do
that'll make him snap
tip me over the edge oh he yeah
yeah real dad could never call me a
[ __ ] tip me over the edge rudolph could
never call me a [ __ ] i'm from the cake
with his face
i'm throwing the whole cake on his face
it's done the wedding is done when it's
done it's done it's done it's time it's
done
bro
i think i would end up going doing a
young back and forth with my man if i'm
sitting down trying to eat my salmon and
he comes up to behind me that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] off right
i'll wait till i need to go piss yeah
yeah yeah and i'll rub his shoulders
from by and rub his traps
big man
after this wedding's done your kneecaps
are finished
i hope you specialize in orthopedics big
man because you're gonna need them bro
you're done tense you're done that's
gonna be tense
you'll hear the china clanking dead you
wanna be able to look back and i'll just
rub harder and harder on his shoulders
you're done out here
looking back like this yeah [ __ ] yeah
you feel that yeah that's a real man
yeah there's a real man i've been taking
care of her name's pom-pom
that's when he launches the plate when
he mentioned renee that's when he
launches the plate and the knives he's
vex your daughter's been calling me
daddy for years big man who are you who
are you bruv wait do you stand up where
do you [ __ ] stand up call me [ __ ]
okay now [ __ ] it there you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you worthless little [ __ ]
you've been turned out two yards big man
you're a joke
you're a joke that would cut him you're
a joke that way he will find you in the
toilet family he will find you in a
toilet find me
that's what i'm hoping for
find me oh yeah no one's real dad could
touch that [ __ ] to me like that nah bro
that's beef
sounds like it brother mel egos are
tough it is oh my egos are tough they
are they are they are they are minus um
it's a different kind of fish it's a
very i feel like it's a very rare occur
maybe not very rare but from my life
it's it's like a rare thing my life as
well but i reckon when it happens
because to be fair i was watching i was
actually watching a thing
uh like i think it was 24 hours in
police custody i might have brought it
up before there was a situation like
that where one homeboy
um
there was a guy he had a son with his
misses
they broke up he sees his son
whenever
and he hates the new man that's living
in the yard the son or the ex
the ex hates new man okay so every time
he drops his son off it's words they're
having words one day words get a little
bit heated the dad grips is the homeboy
homeboy
stabs the living [ __ ] out of him kills
him on the spot the sun's there the
mum's there everything
[ __ ] off stabs him brother did man have
a knife in the first place yeah he was
cooking in the kitchen
stabbed him bruv killed him
then dipped
killed him and dipped
they saw him on the cctv running through
the cul-de-sac fam sprinting [ __ ]
that's gonna mess up the child man oh
100
100 that's an impulsive reaction now
it's going to mess up that child 100 bro
so yeah when these things happen they
happen yeah
yeah it's mad
not me boy
anyway i'll stay in the living room
thanks
[Laughter]
i've got time for no one to drive beef
me about nothing [ __ ] all of that yeah
man um why look if i actually have got a
fan request oh hit me oh
speak okay okay speaking of kind of like
parental
such and such
this one's going to trigger you
this one's going to trigger you if you
had okay
i'm warning you now right so this is a
girl yeah i'm in a small dilemma and was
wondering about what you guys think it's
kind of what would you do in this
situation yeah yeah to summarize i'm 18
and recently got into a relationship
with my current boyfriend around august
we attended the same sixth form and
would always playfully flirt here and
there
but things got more serious as time went
on we live close by and i've been on a
few dates but the furthest thing
we've done is make out sessions he's now
jokingly um talking about
taking things further and i would like
to
but i'm moving at a slower pace because
i haven't lost my v card yet
he knows this and doesn't pressure me
however
he's now joking about considering to
cheat on me if i keep denying to sleep
with him and it's kind of put me off the
whole idea
[ __ ] not surprised bro in his eyes
it's only sex so it wouldn't really be
cheating
that is the actual
essence of cheating it's only sick so it
wouldn't really be cheating but i feel
different
i don't know if this is a red flag for
me
um to leave or just let it happen and
get it over with rawr
she's been manipulated fam she's been
manipulating from wow it's clear she's
18.
it's clear as day she's 18.
is it finished it's finished say what
you need to say fam i'm going to store
it up say what you need to say give me a
recap again car recap
so 18 year old girl
lives near her boyfriend they've got she
got a new boyfriend yeah they live near
each other they spend decent amount of
time together they went to sixth form
together
um the most heated things i've got is a
few make-out sessions and he's trying to
progress the thing she kind of wants to
but she's scared because she's still a
virgin
so she really wants to take things slow
and he started making a few digs here
and there um and basically saying now
hey man if you if you're not trying to
free it up i'm trying to bang someone
else
um and she's like ah that's not funny
and then he's like to be fair i wouldn't
even be cheating it's just not
and she's i guess sorry
man
is your daughter
imagine that is your daughter that's
manipulation
no wonder women hate men bro no wonder
women hate men
babes homeboys are [ __ ] scumbag wow
joker no joke homeboy is a scumbag you
should never ever ever be put in that
corner he literally put you in the
corner babes the man said i'm just
probably going to cheat on you anyway
nah
nah bro
nah bro now you need to remove yourself
from that situation because once you let
him [ __ ] you
that's it like he's yours
he's yours like he's gonna continue to
manipulate and he's gonna cheat on you
100 he's gonna keep cheating on you 100
percent and he's going to just he's just
going to say the same thing it's just
sex it's just it's just sex it's just
something it's actually cheating it's
not even it's just this i didn't even
care about her
about you nah babes remove yourself from
that situation she's a waste man give me
a virginity for whoever you want to
release it too darling it's not it's not
that time yet for you the fact that you
actually feel big boy pressured no i
could never as a as a as if i was her
dad i could never have hear that
conversation oh never
never
never i'm removing his head from his
neck
never
big man i can never hear that never
that's um nah you already know what to
do man just remove your situation it's
not it's not worth it yeah i don't
necessarily feel like you
thought we were going to say that but
wow that's just one of the worst things
i've ever heard yeah she definitely
didn't and it's that's why i said it's
clear that she's 18 and she's young
because
the fact that she
doesn't even know that it's manipulation
the fact that she's lit is working as
well because she said i don't even know
if i should just
let it happen and get it over with just
to stop my man chatting she said she
doesn't know if she considered it a red
flag or something like this yeah she's
saying um
i don't know if this is a red flag for
me to leave
or just let it happen and get it over
with nah man nah he's
he's made you seem like you're the
villain in this whole story
it's nuts whoa
nuts nuts no that is tier one
manipulation
he needs to get axed off 100 100 leave
that situation and um keep it moving
keep your v card till you're ready to
lose it darling it's not worth it yeah
that's definitely not worth it i'm a big
advocate for couples coming together and
bumping uglies but
yeah man can't say if you don't bang me
i'm going to [ __ ] someone else for you
to feel bad and think maybe i should
just bang him then no man that's this
gust in chat he's going to own you after
that yeah he's going to own you if
you've got a big brother run him two
years yeah yeah yeah if you've got big
brother run him over to him if you've
got a big brother just tell him what you
just told us oh just tell him what you
just told us isn't his nose is gonna
spread across his face like nutella
[ __ ] my little sister could never
tell me a man tom told her that
that's nuts i'll i'd say invite him over
right now so you've got three yards
invite him over right now
and you're ready to do the deed tell him
now in fact give me the phone i'm gonna
tell myself
bro nah i could never hear that [ __ ]
that's not cool that's disgusting
i'm not here for that whatsoever i find
that so grotesquely hideous
it's a shame it's a shame that men have
to do that not even half they do that
choose to do that that's um yeah that's
disgusting behavior
leave that situation
um yeah hopefully it's hopefully you
lose your v card to someone you actually
like and takes care of you
yeah we don't usually get sentimental
about prom like that we don't we
literally don't that actually broke my
heart when i read that that's nuts the
fact that you're thinking you are the
villain
is is nuts to me yeah you know you're
denying man not to me
nobody intended but um yeah
leave
leave yeah be gone leave leave leave
anyway
we're gonna move on to um
more twitter hall of twitter hall of
fame oh god i'm terrified
these ones
i wanted to finish off from the last one
so i don't know how funny these ones are
gonna be oh see these are like back at
the back of the the pile the back of the
power button you never know all right so
just never know right let me compose
myself
i'm gonna start with this one this i
don't know why the the pictures oh that
baked beans one last time i'm telling
you i can't stop thinking about it i
don't i know
come on come on when you have a foot
fetish and the pilot says you're flying
over 33 000 feet
[Laughter]
for the audio listeners you have to
pause it hop onto the youtube but just
pre what we just posted
you just got young jerry just
that's disgusting bub
uh anyway
um
this
this tarzan guy was a was hornier than a
drunk nun and not even toilet trained
but jane said you know what those abs
don't grow in trees my hot girl summer
fair fam
i watched tarzan probably like last year
or maybe earlier this year
man's
with that animated or they're a real
life one animated okay
for a children's film man grips are up
is it family when he when he when he
rocks up on his knuckles and he's smells
like tom tom yeah fam the dress starts
getting yanked that says huh ah and she
has to smack him down
consensual non-consent
that stop it but never stop stop it
ravage me ravage me you jungle guy
ravage me
but yeah that was mad oh i ain't seen
timmy turner wish for a big dick once he
must be packing that shmeet
fairly your parents
that's hilarious bro i used to love
fairly old parents
[ __ ] you know i wanted to die after my
ex left me but then i met a [ __ ] that
let me tie her up and put my put my
thumb up her ass life is about growth
facts that's banging
that's banging yeah
whoever hashed the brown boy you deserve
an award
so true and the hashbrowns are different
bro hashbrowns are different i've never
been into hash browns but i'll tell you
the combination if you go to mcdonald's
order a bacon roll mm-hmm right never
breakfast i know you wouldn't bro go to
mcdonald's you order their bacon roll
with ketchup
you pay an extra 40p for a sausage in
there as well then flat sausage sausage
yeah and then you get a hash brown slap
that [ __ ] in there as well yeah
delectable
swear
bro hash browns are banging you don't
like hair bundles on your shades no you
can pay me to eat a hashbrown just give
me you can pay me to just give me a
hashbrown on a year i probably could
yeah
i mean yeah i could
but i'd wish you wouldn't say less he's
i can't just eat avocado yeah like if
you gave me a fork for that i've gotta
make me gag yeah i have a hashtag you
can't i can't just eat a hashbrown
that's me like a burger or something
yeah it has to be insane but when it's
inside end slappity fair enough i love
browns anyway
i only ne
i only lit up so [ __ ] in prison can go
outside
and clean that [ __ ] up
oh
[ __ ] that think [ __ ] think getting
me pregnant okay what [ __ ] think
getting pregnant sorry is gonna trap me
[ __ ] i will kill myself
fab that took a turn fam that took a
time sometimes i took a time but i
literally sometimes you can tell people
who tweet on a regular yeah
they go and they're going they get lost
and they think this is bare funny and
they throw out there and it's like oh i
don't know i should have
any love at all
i miss the times where men would go to
war and just die
again yeah
proof's in the pudding yeah what's going
on with these
what is going on with these
dark
how do girls swallow [ __ ]
this [ __ ] tastes awful
and [ __ ] replied [ __ ] repeat that one
more time
well
there's some variation of this i would
have asked you before okay literally i
can't be bothered for the for the hoo-ha
bro okay give me a number
drop on your finger of your seed yeah
i said i can't be bothered
you know me already
you're gonna do safety you're gonna say
i'm not doing it no i'm not doing it and
then we're going to get down to the crux
of it and it'll be a tenner so just tell
me the number little mom
tell me the number one drop on your
index just my own nut your own nut
oh um
oh
a grand
that's fair yeah mine one drop of mine
probably a mill a mill yeah
who's you say as if you're running me
the pee
i'm not tasting you're not brother five
hundred thousand
is that what you're telling me to do it
for is that something you i'm telling
you to do it for five hundred thousand
i would have dashed this in your face
man's trying to barter with me i don't
want his own nut because i want to know
the truth
i know it's in there because you ain't
seen money like that
right now do it for 500 bucks oh okay
cool of course 300.
of course i do all right i love this now
189
i think you would but i'm not certain
but i think you would 189k
question
yes how am i getting this nut cool i was
actually going to elaborate that well i
thought you might think that because i
was just about to say i'm not going to
put my tool on the tip of your finger
and then just yeah
like
smear it like squish squeeze and wipe oh
god i'm not gonna do that yeah i think
like a petri dish i will not in a petri
dish and you just have to go
you did you just have to get your finger
and go like that
so you've just got a wholesome droplet
and then what the thought of it is
making me gag i know it is that's why
we're that's why you're making the big
money
189 000 one lick 200 bags round up to
200.
all right
you
to your nut
to be honest
one drop of you're not yeah
i'll be violently sick after
violently sick
um i'll be violently sick before yeah
but i'll do it for
i'll probably do it for like 75k
and i know you would as well
if i did it first
if i did it first licked you or not and
you were like nah nah and then you saw
my account
and the man said and you
it's you do it it's exactly the meme
where it says if you man do it i'll do
it
hilarious yeah if i saw 75 bags just
trickle into your account in my barclays
no overdraft pay family credit cards
paid or double dip
just that would you okay cool if you
actually saw that yeah okay this is
actually the truth so if you've seen me
do one dip yeah and i was like yeah yeah
yeah but i actually just gag you saw me
gag twice and i was like [ __ ] you know
man and on vex but then i opened up my
online banking and you saw it go
yeah and then i was like oh gang credit
card paid credit card paid overdraft
paid like oh snap i got peace and i'm
gassed and you're like holy [ __ ] he's
actually got the money
and then homeboy turned the like judy kr
turned to you and said
like you but you you turned me down the
first time
so now you need to go ah
for the same amount of people would you
do it
and i'm like i'm in the back like mom
i'm here i'm loving my life i'm already
over it i'm already over it i don't even
remember doing it i'm just gas i've got
pee
and i'm like fam what's the distance i
put the phone right here yeah and i'm
like bro yeah
once you're finished i'm assuming you're
doing it yeah
yeah i'm on the phone to demands once
you're finished mobs
now
yeah yeah mom's what are you saying what
are you saying
hurry up
what are you saying
how how
far away is the judiciary from me
don't know um he can be as close or as
far as you need him to be
i'm gonna do it yeah and then i'm a
rocky's draw
for adding that contingency
i'm gonna do it wait till the p runs in
my account and then my rockies draw
cool all right say less that's fair
that's fair that's a [ __ ] prick for
that yeah all right all right it's a
prick for that all right
[ __ ] awesome
that was funny though
all right
now breakups in china must be way worse
you've got to see your ex's face
everywhere
i'm not gonna justify that with a laugh
i'm not going to
that's racist
and we don't stand for that here at smg
you can love what you want i'm not gonna
tell you
i'm not going to justify that
nah that's not on
oh
i've seen this one before
my toxic masculinity doesn't like when a
babe sends babe says to me
message me so i know you got home safe
it should be the streets that should
message you when you get home i am the
[Laughter]
no oh that's danger
oh [ __ ] that's funny i think that's it
that's reminds me of um do you mind
breaking bad yeah where um
what's his what's homeboy's main name
walter walter sorry well i lose it
if some reason hank was in my head and i
think i know it's not hank hang moody
californication um
is his brother-in-law called hank as
well
maybe maybe that's why
i can't remember but anyway walter when
um
when skyler's getting on his tits brav
skyler's getting on his last [ __ ]
nerf juggly tits i remember i hated her
i think i hated her
yeah yeah i don't want to give a [ __ ]
about his nasty tits
i don't give a [ __ ] of a scabby old tits
bro she i hated that woman with passion
passion
um
she was only happy when he's banging in
the backseat of the car because he
always has
the hardest about eight seasons whatever
it is every time she was happy when she
was getting banged in the back of the
car scared
um
when she's chucking it to to um to
walter and he has enough
and he turns around on a on a do you
know who you're talking to t
do you know who i am do you know how
much money i make a year
like when they say something like a like
billion dollar operation boom vanished
because i stopped working and it said
something
like he says something along the lines
of like we don't need to be worried
about who's coming knocking in the night
because i'm the one who knocks
i'm the danger i'm the one who comes
knocking he
listen was it brian cranston is that
yeah actor oh have you seen your honor
not yet
but i just bought
i paid for subscriptions fam you and i
was thinking about that yesterday you
and me i just bought now tv because i
don't have skype so i've got now tv and
you're on was on there obviously and i'm
just looking at all the things and i've
got subscript i've got crunchyroll i've
got netflix i've got now tv i've got
prime
i've got all these things i've got prime
i've got funimation instead of
crunchyroll i've got prime netflix
obviously psn
psn is what i've got
what else have i got seven pound a month
i don't see the benefit of well i can't
even remember the rest i've got loads
bro loads [ __ ] [ __ ] bro i'm sick
i forget i've got skype i don't know how
you can afford that
sky's expensive bro it depends on what
you buy how much do you spend a sky
because last time i asked you as uppers
of 100 pounds it's 67 a month i'm still
a lot but yeah fair enough
um
but yeah man brian cranston is a real
guy your honor he brian cranston is
the perfect actor
that can show
like panic yeah yeah yeah yeah
he knows how to deal with panic but he
also knows how to show he's panicking
yeah yeah yeah in both in both series
incredible yes incredible when you put
him in a corner
when you put brian in the corner
wow the things he does the things he's
capable of
yeah wow you need to see your runner bro
all right and i'm gonna start um
a night off
if i had the choice of what you watch
and don't watch
everything you're watching at the minute
i would tell you to stop really i'm
watching that up a night off is
[ __ ] amazing
as far as drama series go yeah so if you
put it in the same category as like true
story okay um and just like i don't know
short
short passionate drama series i won't
put it in the ones with multiple seasons
limited series limited series
yeah
easily if if
if would if true story was a seven out
of ten a knight of his 11 really and
that was probably the best limited
series i've ever seen in my life i can't
think of anything the better
really i know i was [ __ ] amazing bro
but
i know we've had discussion before but
i'm even more i'm gonna double down in
it it's amazing bro yeah man by the time
we record our next one i would have seen
at least a couple episodes so i'll get
into it okay okay all right we've got a
little bit more time than i thought we
would so let's do them by the [ __ ]
okay
oh god
oh god
all right
[Music]
let me hit me hit me all right let's go
um what's up but
would you say suck balls bro what did
you say
i was trying to say sup boys
but it came out wrong like sup byes
some vietnamese thing
sup boys
i sound like island boy
have you heard the man you have an
island boys i'm an island boy
i'm an island boy i'm saying
i'm an island you see island boys
big man let me show you island boy real
quick tick tock tick yeah
most useless humans these two twin
brothers bro
the most useless humans bro
i'm ireland boy that's all that's all i
hear when i hit island
i'm an island boy
i'm an island oh come on adverts bro
a gift and a curse
yeah lines our pockets but
ruins my day
shut up shut up
i've seen them i just swipe i don't even
give them my time of day
you they don't deserve it fair enough
they don't deserve it but [ __ ] out
ireland boys yeah anyway sup why
love the pogba i gotta get something off
my chest
right when i was 16
um i had sex for the first time and i
did not once think uh fam there's i'm
gonna say it's ahead of schedule there's
plot holes in here
he's trying to swind he that
he don't watch the show as frequently as
he's trying to swindle your boys in this
one okay and i'm not going to stand for
it and we're going to be there for him
but i'm not going to stand for it for a
second maybe listen bro all right let me
hear me hit me sup why
love the pod but go get something off my
chest yeah when i was 16 i had sex for
the first time and did not once think
about a condom
this was this was because pawn i watched
never did wear one so i didn't realize i
needed one until i was about to bust
okay a year and a half later i heard
that she has had a baby
she did not reach out to me once but we
really liked each other so i would think
so we think should
i think he meant to say she would have
if it was mine
it's been a few years i've moved
countries if she hasn't reached out now
do i have anything to worry about
reason this is still on my mind here and
there is because i think i pulled out
late am i the [ __ ] for not reaching
out i am too scared to but i can't find
any socials anyway
right so recap
when he was 16 he lost his v to one yeah
didn't strap up
quote unquote thinks he pulled out late
uh he found out that a year and well a
year and a half later he'd found out
that she'd had a baby
um
she hasn't reached out to him to tell
him whether it's his or not or if he
should even think it was his he might be
overreacting he might not be um he wants
to reach out now it's been a few years
but he can't find any of her socials and
he just thinks about it now and again
because he's fairly certainly pulled out
late
i mean losing your vs uh how old was
that one last movie 17 i
think
and it's one of those ones where
because we are who we are now we're 30
year old grown men
thinking about pulling out yes it's
still difficult but it's a lot easier
for us now in the sense that we've had
practice yeah yeah yeah yeah
he said he lost to virginia that time
right yeah
so i can understand the fear factor in
it like i'm not necessarily been in his
shoes obviously with 16 year old blah
blah blah situation but i can understand
the fear factor of
overthinking if he pulled out enough or
pulled out in time rather thinking oh my
god a year and a half later she's got
you could it be mine
not being able to find her on socials it
constantly being on your mind like i can
understand
where he's coming from what was he easy
they also for what fun for not reaching
out but not reaching out i mean yes and
no at the time you could have reached
out
um when you did have a social or did
have contact with yeah because you
banged her a year and a half later when
you when you first heard about it first
thought about it you could reach out you
could have you 100 could have and should
have reached out again i understand the
fear i understand it was your first time
i understand all of these things but
i think she would she definitely would
have respected you a bit more if um not
to say she doesn't respect it because
obviously we don't know that um but i
think she would have appreciated that a
bit more if you did reach out and
explain the situation and say oh big man
is it mine easily done is it mine easily
done i don't want to be that guy yeah
but is it mine or not mine or not i
should be like are you joking
and you'll be done it would be done and
you wouldn't have you won't be sweating
this you've been thinking about it yeah
think about this for years um i said
he's moved country yeah the reason i
said those plot holes was that man said
i didn't even think about condoms
until i was about to not
the reason it sounds like a plot hole to
me is because
he
justified it with the exact reason why
he didn't think about it it's like the
human brain in my opinion doesn't work
like that
like if you genuinely aren't thinking
about something
late when you have hindsight you can't
say oh the sole reason i didn't think
about it was because of this like that's
it's not how it works that's just not
how the human brain works if you didn't
think about it you didn't think about it
yeah there's no there's no there's
nothing in your brain that says oh by
the way the reason we didn't think about
that back then was because of this so
you can be like oh yeah that makes sense
it's like nah there could be a million
reasons why you didn't think about it
but there's better times i haven't
thought about a johnny
um
but also
there hasn't
johnny's always it's always
regardless it was my first time bro
i had johnny's before i'd even had sex
had way before i had sex your boy was
practicing in the in
in the dunya
um so yeah that bit was especially to me
the fact that he said he didn't even
cross my mind
um
but neither again it uses information at
this point yeah just say a banger raw
and i'm not even sure if i pulled out in
time or not which if you're not sure it
means you didn't
that's the cardinal rule
that's the cardinal rule if you're not
sure it means you didn't
that's tough mum but i hope you have
reached out to her and i hope you will
reach out to her and just ask her man
get off your chest get off your chest
literally get off your chest but then
again i think
i think if it was yours she would have
found out she would have found you yeah
she would have found you by now yeah i'm
fairly certain i'm 98 certain it's not
yours but
if it is and you're desperate to find
out then
i'll just literally find a way there's
always gonna be a way to find her
messenger stupid question
five years ago we had sex a year later i
finally had a baby i don't know why
she's coming to my head right now just
for clarification is it not mine is it
don't question i don't know but he's not
mine is it
um no it's not okay cool just wants to
fam if i've sent that after five years
and i immediately see red and i see dot
dot dot i'm shaking my heart i'm gonna
close my phone close the whole laptop
whichever device i'm using brother
i would be so
scared oh same bro i'm one million
percent if it was on instagram i will
send the message on instagram once it's
sent i'm deleting the message i don't
want to know where she's ready i don't
want to know anything i'm deleting it
bro [ __ ] and then every single time i
see that little one in the right hand
corner i'm breaking it this quick swipe
swipe yeah
[Laughter]
anyway guys um
we've gotta love you and leave you again
this week if you had fun today jump on
thursday three days away patreon three
pound a month tempe a day yeah if you're
not on the patreon we'll see you in
seven days time
and yeah man happy new year again let's
have a great year this is going to be
big for us and it's going to be big for
you love you guys
bless
[Music]